so yesterday I played for you a clip
from this past weeks Face the Nation
program on CBS where the interviewer
Margaret Brennan I believe her name was
tried to play these weird semantic games
with Bernie Sanders maybe under the
guise of being sensible devil's advocacy
and it was all about Donald Trump's
belligerence on Iran and Bernie rightly
had absolutely none of it and he said
clearly and plainly bombing Iran would
have been an act of war check out that
clip I did it earlier in the week and I
won't replay it for you today but today
I have another one of these just strange
attempts to sort of sandbag Bernie
Sanders yesterday was the day of debate
one part one debate one for the 2020
Democratic primary is split into two
nights one night was yesterday the
second night is tonight Bernie Sanders
is participating tonight but he was
interviewed before part one of the
debate yesterday by MSNBC and he was
interviewed by Casey hunt who I guess
was trying to play hardball with Bernie
Sanders in some way I don't even really
know what it is that she was trying to
do but she starts trying to sandbag him
about will you get out before the
convention if you aren't going to be the
nominee because some say that you hurt
Hillary Clinton by staying in this thing
last time around which is not exactly
how I remember it going by the way which
makes no sense to ask specifically to
Bernie if you're not asking every
candidate because Bernie's in the second
place what about asking every single one
of these candidates with 0.6 percent or
1.2 percent support that are clogging up
the stage
they made the requirements right I'm not
saying that by virtue of the
requirements they shouldn't be there
they made the requirements to be on the
debate stage but clogging it up timewise
and letting us not really hear any depth
from the candidates that have a shot
what about asking them are they gonna
get out on Monday which many of them
should and this just starts to get
really weird and Bernie again points out
are you going to ask this to every
candidate what is this line of
questioning and then when the will you
get out line falls apart on Casey hunt
she goes with are you a Democrat in this
completely sarcastic and condescending
way just a really disgusting interview
take a look at this if
it's clear that you are not going to be
the Democratic nominee will you leave
the race before the convention I intend
to be the Democratic nominee but if
you're not you study and some people say
well no some people say that if maybe
that system was not rigged against me I
would have won the nomination and
defeated Donald Trump that's what some
people say so I think we're going to
play it out I think I am excited we take
the risk I'm excited it's done are you
asking out of every candidate I'm saying
if you are not going to dominate you
well right now we are planning to win
the Democratic nomination and I'm proud
of the campaigns were running in Iowa
and in New Hampshire and are proud of
our grassroots support and the fact that
we have a million volunteers I'll go
right now is the win it and by the way
as you may know poll after poll shows
what against Trump chose me beating
Trump by 8 9 or 10 points we're going to
be Trump we're going to win the
Democratic nomination are you a Democrat
course on the Denver cano this is a
Democratic National Convention a
Democratic primary yeah right all right
that's an easier answer to that question
I feel like we got in 2016 senator
Bernie Sanders thank you very much I do
she says he hurt Hillary's candidacy
when I think back to 2016 I don't recall
Hillary being hurt by Bernie I remember
Bernie being hurt by the DNC I remember
Hillary Clinton being hurt by James
Comey sure I remember Hillary being hurt
in the general election
partially by her own decisions about
where to campaign and where to not
campaign this is a really I don't even
know what to call it it's a soft sophist
attempt to sandbag Bernie Sanders by
Casey hunt and before yesterday's debate
I'll admit it had been months since I
last watched MSNBC I turned it on
yesterday before the debate because I
wanted to see how are they previewing it
who is commenting is this type of stuff
comment on there now because it seems to
have gotten really really bad these are
not the important questions for Bernie
Sanders there are all sorts of questions
that could have been asked to Bernie
that would have been more interesting
and I understand if you are going to ask
Bernie about this ask Gillibrand when
she
is getting out ask Tim Ryan when he's
getting out there's so many people
polling under 1% of a Amy Klobuchar
Inslee Hickenlooper Delaney Gabbard I
mean though these people are under 1% if
not under 2% are we asking them when
they're getting out because they could
probably get out Monday and it would be
reasonable Bernie will support whoever
is the nominee we know this this line of
questioning is absurd I'm glad that in
the Sunday interview with CBS and in
this one Bernie is not allowing himself
to be steamrolled with these absurd
questions and the most important thing
is everything that is happening is anti
depth and anti discussing issues a
debate with 10 people on stage each
night with a minute answers and
30-second rebuttals only from some of
the candidates on each question lets us
learn almost nothing about their
positions and about how to fix problems
facing us this type of interview doesn't
create a conversation where we deepen
our understanding of for example
Bernie's foreign policy I am one of the
first to admit bernie is weakest on
foreign policy relative to other areas
it would have been great to just talk
about foreign policy in detail for
example would bernie be open to
alternatives to medicare for all that in
other countries have worked really well
talking about the Canadian system or the
British system or whatever right I mean
there's substantive stuff that you can
actually play devil's advocate with and
confront Bernie about which would be
useful this is I'm coming up with these
just kind of randomly those would all be
more substantive than will you get out
if you're losing before the convention
or are you a Democrat I don't know if
this stuff is now common on MSNBC again
because I don't really watch any of this
stuff I have no idea but I want to hear
from you like it is this what MSNBC has
become because it's not great today's
sponsor is Skillshare and I'm excited to
tell you that everybody in our audience
is getting two entire months of free
access to Skillshare when you click the
link underneath this video skill shares
the site that offers over 25,000 online
courses on almost any topic you can
imagine cooking meditation photography
video editing Photoshop Man
a small business almost an endless list
and whether you're trying to get ahead
in your career maybe you want to learn
new skills that will make you better at
your job you might just be exploring a
new hobby and you're trying to find new
ways to be creative in your personal
time skill shares the perfect place to
fully immerse yourself in whatever
you're trying to learn I really enjoyed
the class on more advanced video editing
techniques because it's something I've
been wanting to improve at but have been
very busy hosting the david packard show
for the last few years
once again the david pakman show is
giving you two whole months of access to
every single class offered by Skillshare
after those two months if you want to
keep your subscription Skillshare super
affordable at less than ten bucks a
month get better at whatever it is that
you're passionate about or discover
something brand new that you didn't even
know that you would love and join skill
shares other 7 million users by clicking
the link underneath this video
[Music]